a lot has changed this year we've got a
worldwide pandemic we're all stuck
working from home so why not make the
most out of your time at home that's why
today we're talking about the top five
technologies you should learn in 2021 so
let's get started with number five we
have augmented virtuality and extended
reality in 2021 we can expect these
forms of technologies being further
integrated into our lives usually
working in tandem with some of the other
technologies we've mentioned in the list
ar and vr is expected to play a huge
role in the field of health care by
providing training simulations to help
medical professionals and for opticians
to perform eye tests it is also to play
a huge role in the educational sector
greatly improving the interactivity the
vr video and gaming market is expected
to grow to 2.9 and 2 billion in 2021
respectively snap microsoft atnt and
nexus studios are some of the major
companies working towards ar and vr you
need skills like software development ar
vr maintenance support design slash
graphics and hardware engineering to
work in this sector at number 4 we have
dark dark is an emerging technology that
several major industries have their
sights on
dark is a combination of distributed
ledger technology artificial
intelligence extended reality and
quantum computing accenture who
introduced dark beliefs that these
technologies combined could have an
enormous impact on technology as a whole
dark is now primarily geared towards the
healthcare industry where it is expected
to lower the cost of care improve labor
productivity and enable better
experiences for consumers and partners
due to its currently developing nature
only a few organizations have started
taking advantage of this technology to
get into dark you'll need skills related
to each of its contributing technologies
like dlt ai xr and quantum computing
next up at number three as a service
cloud services are expected to provide
even more services that make technology
like ai and robotics accessible to every
business
thanks to companies like google
microsoft amazon a number of startups
and innovators cutting edge technology
is accessible to everyone with little
investment serverless computing is also
something that's being focused on as it
provides users the opportunity to work
on the core product without operating
and managing the servers
hybrid cloud is also expected to show
great growth thanks to its speed ease of
control and security options the global
iaas paas and saas market size is
supposed to grow to 81 billion dollars
72 billion dollars and
140.6 billion us dollars respectively to
get into cloud computing you'll need to
have an understanding of the concepts
like different cloud computing platforms
programming languages specialize in
services belonging to compute storage
database domains and so on now let's
talk about number two automation with an
increasing number of potential cases
initiatives towards self-driving
vehicles would be a priority for civic
authorities and many other organizations
across the world this ensures that the
cost of human labor is reduced and
handles customer demand there would also
be an increase in the incorporation of
robots in the care and assisted living
sectors
robotic devices are also expected to
provide companionship to elderly people
drones are also expected to be
incorporated for the delivery of
medicine groceries and other essential
goods some of the popular companies in
the field of automation are siemens
honeywell abb and mitsubishi to get into
automation you will need skills like
programming skills and scripting skills
configuration management software an
understanding of testing tools and so on
and finally at number one artificial
intelligence ai is a field that's
expected to see the most amount of
growth in the next year ai can help
interpret and understand the enormous
amount of content produced machine
learning algorithms would become better
informed and perform much more
sophisticated operations it is expected
to be used to analyze interactions to
determine underlying connections and
insights to help predict demand for
services like hospitals and enable
authorities to make better decisions
about resource utilization ai will be
used by businesses to detect the
changing patterns of customer behavior
and for detecting the various ways they
can be satisfied global spending on
cognitive and ai systems is expected to
reach 57.6 billion dollars by 2021 and
to get into ai you'll need skills like
programming languages linear algebra
probability big data machine learning
algorithms etc on that note why don't
you check out simplylearn's postgraduate
program on ai and machine learning
created in partnership with purdue
university and in collaboration with ibm
we'll cover a number of topics and
concepts like statistics python machine
learning deep learning networks nlp
reinforcement learning and much more to
help you grow in your career and there
you go guys that's our top five
technologies to learn in 2021.
do you think there's something even more
amazing than a.i let us know in the
comment section below thank you for
watching the video and stay tuned for
more from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here